what advice would you give a lot of
young people look up to you what advice
um despite the better judgment no I'm
just kidding I'm just not maybe I'm only
kidding only kidding they uh they
seriously look up to you and draw
inspiration from your ideas from your
bold thinking what what advice would you
give to them how to have how to live a
life worth living how to have a career
they can be proud of
and everything like that so
live out the values that you think are
really important and seek those values
in others I would be the first piece of
advice second piece of advice don't go
on Twitter until you're 26. uh because
your brain is fully developed at that
point uh you know the the as I said
early on you know I was on social media
and writing columns from time I was 17.
it was a great opportunity and as it
turns out a great temptation to say
enormous numbers of stupid things uh
when when you're young I mean you're
kind of trying out ideas and you're
putting them on you're taking them off
and social media permanentizes those
things and engraves them in stone and
then that's used against you for the
rest of your life so I tell young people
this all the time like if you want to be
on social media be on social media but
don't post like watch uh if you want to
take in information and more importantly
you should read books
um as far as you know other advice I'd
say engage in your community
there's no substitute for engaging in
your community and engage in
interpersonal action because that that
will soften you and make you a better
person
I become a better person since I got
married I become an even better person
since I've had kids so you can imagine
how terrible I was before all these
things uh and uh uh engaging your
community it does does allow you to
build the things that matter on the most
local possible level I mean the outcome
by the way of the sort of politics of
the politics fulfillment that I was
talking about earlier is a lot of
localism because the roles that I'm
talking about are largely local roles so
that stuff has to be protected locally I
think we focus way too much in this
country and others on like World beating
Solutions National Solutions solutions
that apply to hundreds of millions of
people how it gets to the solutions that
apply for like five and then we get to
the solutions that apply to like 20 and
then we get to the solutions that
involve 200 people or a thousand people
let's solve that stuff and I think the
solutions at the higher level flow
bottom up not top down